[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRITHPAL BHOGILL: Welcome.
Last year the conference, huh?
Had fun so far?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PRITHPAL BHOGILL: Excellent.
Awesome.
So again, thanks
for taking the time
to come over to the session.
Prithpal Bhogill.
I'm part of the
Apigee product team.
And I'm super excited to
be joined on the stage
here with Gopika Patel
from Global Payments.
She will join us a little
later in the session.
And today we are going to
talk about how do you really
accelerate application
development with cloud
services.
This is actually a topic which
has become very important
as customers are
migrating to the cloud
and transition to the cloud and
using more and more services.
So we will walk you
through some few things.
The first housekeeping
thing out here real quick
is this year at Next, we
have Dory, which is an app
that we use internally
for question and answers.
So inside of your
Google Next app,
you'll see a Dory Q&A link.
Please feel free to ask
any questions out there.
There are also two microphones.
Towards the end of
the session, we'll
be opening it up for Q&A.
So we'll take live questions
and also read questions
from the Dory as well.
OK, with that, so let's
talk a little bit about APIs
and digital transformation.
You may have heard
throughout the conference
around how companies are
trying to transform digitally.
So what does that really mean?
What it really means
at the end of the day
is that they are leveraging
APIs as the front-and-center
mechanism of exploiting their
capabilities to a variety
of different stakeholders.
These stakeholders
could obviously
be employees who are using
some kind of productivity
applications.
It could be your
end consumers who
are using your services
to get some benefit.
Or it could also be a
big partner ecosystem
who are really deriving extended
value from these products.
So these products in the new day
and age are nothing but APIs.
And so if we look at
this picture real quick,
it talks about
your core systems,
such as the core
enterprise digital assets.
Other ones which
have now moved away
from a system level or
integration level detail
to being an API--
those deliver the
connected experiences
that are very important
this day and age.
So, why are we talking
about this today?
Well, what we are
also seeing is as more
and more enterprises
are becoming API first,
they have begun to
move to the cloud
and are also leveraging a
variety of different kind
of cloud services.
So cloud services are great.
They give you the
ability to be able to use
some capability right away.
At the same time, they do
require a specific mechanism
to interact with them.
So on one hand, they do
offer you the entities
to be able to innovate faster.
But you also need to
be able to use them
in a more efficient way.
So let's quickly break
down the anatomy of how
you access a cloud service.
Now, I'm going to use an example
for a Google Cloud service
in general.
But this could very
well and equally
apply to pretty much any
of the cloud service.
So, if you think about
a very typical access
pattern for any cloud
service, or even
your own service for
that matter of fact,
it involves a few key steps.
The very first thing you do
as an application developer--
by the way, how many application
developers or developers
in the house out here today?
Oh, excellent.
Excellent.
So there'll be a
lot more goodness
for you to hear about today.
So, the very first thing
as a developer that you do
is figure out, where are my
credentials to that service
that I want to access?
That's step one.
Then you got to go manage
how you store them.
Second, once I have access
to those credentials, then
usually, most
likely, you're going
to hit some kind
of a token endpoint
where you exchange that
credential for an access token.
That token is supposedly
going to be timestamped,
and which means you have to
manage the life cycle of,
is the token good, do I need to
refresh it, so on and so forth.
And, once you do
all the three steps,
finally, you actually
make a call to the API
that you desire to
invoke, which means
there's a lot of nanosteps.
There's a lot of redundancy
that you have to account for.
It is error prone.
What if you miss a step?
And, more importantly,
this is a common thing
which compliance teams and
administrators do not like.
They don't want developers
touching or messing
with any credentials.
That's a domain they want
developers to stay away from.
How many developers out here
have to work with credentials?
OK.
Just keep your hands up,
please, for a second.
How many out there never get
told by a compliance team
about anything at all?
Are they totally OK with that?
If they are, bring
your hands down.
OK.
So this is a very
common problem, right?
Compliance is usually
behind clean separation
of credentials, provisioning--
that's all compliance and ops.
Using certain capabilities--
that's developers.
So then let's take a
look at how Apigee,
which is a full lifecycle
API management platform,
can really help you develop
these APIs by leveraging some
of these newer cloud services.
So what you see out here
within the picture out here
is Apigee API platform,
also known as Apigee Edge.
It has full-feature capability
to have out-of-the-box policies
to support your
security requirements,
traffic management,
transformation,
so on and so forth.
As you start to go up
in your API program,
you want to ensure that you
have enough capabilities
to be able to expose your API
so they can be consumed easily
by developers.
And then the analytics give
you that clean insight,
and not only from an
operational perspective,
but also from metrics, which
cater to different stakeholders
such as, are the
APIs being used?
Who is using them, right?
So on and so forth.
And now, extensions is
a very useful capability
that we added--
when GA October of last year.
It was announced at Google
Cloud Next in London last year.
And today, we are
pleased to announce
some really cool extensions
that we have made
available to our customers.
But because extensions become
part of the core platform,
you, as a developer who's
leveraging the Apigee platform,
can leverage all the
entities and connect
to those cloud services very
quickly, and more importantly
become more productive
in composing your APIs
and through the leveraging
some of those cloud services.
So as I mentioned, it's all
about acceleration and Apigee
extensions.
As we will see them
today in a demo,
it gives you all
the capabilities
to be able to leverage
those cloud services.
So what are extensions?
We look at them in
three different ways.
So first off, extensions
provide a well-vetted framework,
which gives the ability
for our customers
to be able to take a
policy-based approach
in accessing those
cloud services.
So what that means is, of
course every cloud service is
going to have an API endpoint.
But what we're
talking about here
is giving you as developers
access to those services using
policy-based controls.
Number two, we give you
all the capabilities
so you can reuse your
extensions very rapidly
and avoid the error-prone--
the redundancy issue
that we spoke about.
And last but not the
least, this is our gateway
into providing all
the new innovation.
So as an example, as customers
adopt AI and ML in their APIs,
these extensions
give you the ability
to be able to tap into some
of those services very,
very quickly.
So today, I'm very
pleased to announce
extensions-- general
availability of these five
extensions which take
our catalog to a much
higher number.
So Cloud authentication,
Cloud Functions,
which give the ability to access
protected Cloud Functions,
Cloud Machine Learning
Engine, BigQuery, and then
we have really bumped up the
support for our Data Loss
Prevention extension which
we released last year.
But now we've added
support for templates.
If you have been around
in the conference,
we did demo some
of these extensions
during one other
session as well.
So this brings the total
number of extensions to 16.
And we haven't just stopped
at building extension only
for Google Cloud Services.
If you've been attentive,
you've heard a lot of focus
on hybrid and multicloud.
So today, we'll actually
showcase to you--
and we did in another
session before as well--
that we have gone and built
extensions to other cloud
services as well.
So our customers can
leverage the Apigee platform.
No matter where your workloads
are on which cloud provider,
you're able to seamlessly
access those services as well.
OK, with that, if you can
switch to the demo, please.
Awesome.
So in this
demonstration, I'm going
to walk you through the day in
the life of an API developer.
So, this would be the
persona or the role
who are using the Apigee
API platform for building
all these APIs.
And we'll walk you through how
to leverage extensions and use
these cloud services
to deliver to the APIs.
So, I'm logged into
Apigee Edge out here.
And this is the interface
that I see when I get in.
So I'm logged in out here
as an API developer, right?
In this case, I'm going to
be jumping back and forth
between the API developer
persona and the API
administrator persona as well.
So first off, I
have a requirement
to now go build an API and
get some employee data.
That data happens to
be sitting in BigQuery.
Traditionally, if
I go into Apigee,
I can whip up an API proxy.
An API proxy is nothing but
a very simple construct.
It gives you the ability
to be able to compose
a lot of interaction
with many services.
You can use a lot of different
policies out of the box.
So I could very easily--
let's say an example--
go into one of the APIs.
I'll just look this
one up as an example,
and assuming the demo
gods are with us today,
as they should be.
So within this
API proxy, you can
add a bunch of different
kinds of policies, right?
So I can use traffic management
policies, security, mediation
policies, and I can also use an
extension capability as well.
So it's a very
extensible platform.
So using a combination of
many of these policies,
I can access pretty
much any cloud
service or any other service
that's out there, right?
But that's something which we've
been doing for a long time.
So let's now focus our attention
on how do the extensions come
in and really help that cost.
So with that, I'll
actually first start
with looking at
BigQuery because I'm
going to show you how you're
going to use the BigQuery
extension to get data
in and out of BigQuery
through Apigee Edge.
So in this case, I
switched over to BigQuery.
And I have a data set
called "human_resources"
and a pretty obvious
table called "employees."
In this case, let me run
a quick query in BigQuery.
And once I get the results
out here, assuming you
guys can see this, I have
about seven different entries
in there, OK?
Let me see if I can mess with
the resolution a little bit.
OK, a little bit better, right?
So this is actual
data sitting in there.
So now, let's go over
and see how we can enable
that experience within Apigee.
So the first thing you do
now is you go into this area
where we call Extensions.
So the first step is
go into Extensions
and go Add an Extension.
As you can see,
we have extensions
to a lot of the services
that I just spoke about.
You can click on any of these.
In this case, you
would typically
go and click on BigQuery.
You give it a name
and a description.
So again, this is the
administrator going in,
configuring this extension.
Once you do that--
and for the purpose
of this demo,
I'm going to use an extension
that I created recently.
It's called BQ, or
BigQuery Employees.
Within this extension,
you typically go in
and you enter a few different
prerequisites-- so your GCP
project ID, the same GCP
project that I was just on,
and the service account, or the
credentials-- to call BigQuery.
So I've already deployed an
instance of the extension here.
And you can see, this is up
and running and ready for us
to use.
So in this case, as an
administrator, I come in
and I simply configure
the extension.
I deal with all the credentials.
And this is ready to go.
So now let's switch over to
the API developer persona.
I'm out here building
an API proxy.
And I already built
one for employees.
In this case,
instead of me having
to now deal with a
bunch of other things,
I'm going to use the
Extension Callout policy.
So I'll go out here and
say Extension Callout.
I will select the extension
that I just deployed,
the bq-employees.
And now this will present
me a list of operations
which is already available.
So no longer I have to worry
about go and reference the API
documentation.
I have all the method
that I need out here.
I can select one of them and add
the Extension Callout policy.
It's already added out here.
In this case, we'll
start with the first use
case, which is trying to insert
a new record into BigQuery, OK?
So in this case,
I'm going to call
this flow within Apigee Edge.
And as you can see, it is
trying to put something
that I sent in the request
into that table in BigQuery.
So I'll use the trace
tool real quick.
I'll jump onto a
revision, revision 2.
And I'm going to Postman, which
is a tool that we commonly
use to test stuff.
So let's click on the
Insert Employee function.
So in this case, I have a
simple JSON [? payload. ?]
This is what I'm trying
to insert into BigQuery.
So let's hit Send out here.
And when I do that,
behind the scenes,
it's making a call to the
Apigee Edge API proxy, which
now leverages the extension.
You can see it came
back with a "200 OK."
So far, so good.
So if I go into
the trace tool, I
can see that it did the right
level of security checks, which
is what you would
expect to do in Apigee.
And then it made a
call out to BigQuery
and actually tried to push this
data into a BigQuery table.
So actually, let's
go and query that.
So it should have an ID of 999.
So I go out here,
run another query,
and if this has truly worked,
we should see the last entry out
there, as you can out here, OK?
So again, let's
recap what we did.
Very quickly, we
used an extension,
which was configured
by the administrator.
And the API developer
simply leveraged that policy
and made a call to add
data into BigQuery.
So then let's go over and
run the same thing for yet
another use case.
So in this case,
what I want to do
is I also want to run a list
method, which also happens
to be on the same API proxy.
In this case, I'm reusing
the same extension.
But in this case, I'm calling
the list all roles method.
So if I run this out
here and I hit Send,
you can see that if
this was to work,
it's fetching all the
data from BigQuery, right?
Again, I'm leveraging
these cloud services,
but I'm able to compose my API
in a much more quicker way.
All right, now let's see if we
can use some other capabilities
within the extension.
So in this case,
what I'm going to do
is I will switch over to
the developed app right here
and I will bump this
to revision 3, which
now puts a limit clause.
So in this case, let's make sure
I go and deploy this to "test."
I just created a new
revision of the API proxy
where I'm trying to now
utilize another feature.
So in this case, in the
list-employees Extension
Callout, you can see I used
a limit cloud out here, OK?
So this means it should now
limit the data coming back
from BigQuery.
And I can control that
from within the extension.
So when I go and call
this, it should only
return me one item back, OK?
So far, so good.
So now, well, I see a lot of
PI information is coming out.
But maybe employee
data is sensitive
and I don't really
want to mess with it.
I want to ensure, if a
developer forgets about this,
how do I put in
the right controls
so this data doesn't go away
or doesn't escape the perimeter
of the enterprise boundary.
So, turns out Google
Cloud actually
has a foster extension for that
which is known as the Data Loss
Prevention extension, OK?
So I'm going to show
you an example of this.
Again, it's pretty simple.
I'm switching over
to this console here,
which shows you the
template support.
In this case, you can see that
here is the template from DLP.
Data Loss Prevention API
has support for templates.
In this case, I'm going to use
the specific template which
will show you how data can
be masked coming out of it.
In order to do that, I'm
going to switch back out here.
And I will turn to revision 4
which had that policy already
configured.
And I will deploy that.
While that is deploying,
I will showcase
another important
console within Apigee.
Now, this is something which,
you know, fosters reuse.
Shared Flows is a set
of reusable policies
that I can use and enforce
across all different APIs.
So within this shared
flow, which is something
that you can call
from an API proxy,
I have a few different things.
And the fourth thing is,
as you may have guessed,
it uses the DLP template.
It uses the DLP
extension and tries
to call that same template that
we just reviewed very briefly.
It will go and apply that
onto your payload, OK?
So within the API
proxy, going backward
for a second, if I
click on "employees,"
you can see in
revision 4 I'm making
a call to the shared flow
using a FlowCallout policy.
And the shared flow has the
Data Loss Prevention extension
configured.
So, now let's take it
for a real quick spin.
And now if I was
to just run this,
it should hopefully mask the
data coming out of BigQuery.
So once it returns, what's
really happening out
here is I've just simply
taken this API proxy
and just added another
extension to it
called Data Loss Prevention.
Where it goes-- you
get data from BigQuery
first because still
using that extension,
and then takes that information,
apply data loss prevention,
and then mask the data
coming out of it, right?
So hopefully that
gave you a taste
of what the extensions are.
I really quickly
want to showcase
some of the other extensions
that we also built.
Other than the Google
Cloud services,
you can see we have extensions
to support different cloud
providers.
They're generally
available and out there
for you folks to try it out.
So with that, if we can switch
back to the presentation.
And at this point
in time, I would
like to invite over Gopika
Patel from Global Payments.
[APPLAUSE]
GOPIKA PATEL: Thank
you, Prithpal.
How are we doing, guys?
Thursday, last day, after
lunch, we are all set.
[LAUGHS] All right.
OK, guys.
And Prithpal, by the way,
cool, new announcements
for the extensions,
specifically the DLP one.
We might look into
using that pretty soon.
All right, so, guys,
I'm Gopika Patel.
I lead the Enterprise
Integrations team
at Global Payments.
Here with me, I have the
Global Payments team.
Say hi, guys.
[LAUGHS]
All right.
So, what do we do?
So, my team is responsible
for identifying
the common shared services
needs across the enterprise.
We build, design, deploy,
support the common shared
services across the enterprise.
Enterprise Integrations is
an extension of Enterprise
Architecture responsibilities.
And with me, I have--
and Ali's going to shoot me.
We have Ali Fawaz, who is the
Senior Vice President and Chief
Enterprise Architect
at Global Payments.
Say hi, Ali.
All right.
At Global Payments, we
are today's innovators
of tomorrow's payments
and technology solutions.
Cool sentence.
I got it from my PR guys.
But, so we are a leading
worldwide provider
for payment technology
as offer solutions,
driving innovative services
to our customers globally.
Our technology
services and employees
enables us to deliver a broad
range of solutions for payment
services so that our customer
can focus on their businesses
efficiently and
basically market and use
the products across various
distributed payment channels.
How many of you we have, like,
fintech or financial services
audience here?
Just raise your hand.
Fintech, wow.
PCI-- we all love it.
We have Stacy, our compliance
lead, here with us.
Some facts and figures
for Global Payments.
This basically shows
the size of our company.
We do have over 2.5
million businesses.
We support approximately 200,000
new customers or merchants
here.
140 payment methods, 2.5K
global sales professionals,
$3.5 billion in net
revenues, 11,000 employees,
32 countries-- pretty
spread out globally--
17 million
transactions per year,
of course, customer support
24/7, 30 different languages.
So that's Global Payment's
test of our size.
So, I want to talk about
how Global Payments leverage
Apigee gateway today.
One of the biggest
project, if you will,
we have is Unified
Commerce Platform.
We launched it a
couple of weeks ago.
And what is Unified
Commerce Platform?
So with the Unified
Commerce Platform,
we plan to deliver
the set of APIs
which our customers or merchant
developers can integrate with.
Easy, seamless, easy-to-use
integration, simple,
hiding the complexity
of the backend services
at the gateway.
We receive a transaction
We mediate it and transfer
it to the appropriate backend
processors, backend
services, and there you go.
So, these APIs-- we also
leverage Apigee's developer
portal.
So our customer developers,
internal and external,
can go to the developer portal,
take a look at this API test,
basically, quote
unquote, "touch" the API,
make the test execution course,
which comes to our integration
environments, and basically
run the test from the portal.
And there you go.
We have developers now who can
use this and go to these APIs
from the portal itself.
Our plan is to have a full
self-service customer base
or developer base that
we want to eliminate
any sort of handholding
in very near future.
So, yep.
It says up on the slides, one
integration enabling payments
worldwide across any
channel or device.
Let me switch to this one.
So this is, obviously, a
very high-level architecture
of the Unified
Commerce Platform.
We do have various sets of APIs
on the gateway transactions
from the fintech
industry-- you know,
the transaction or authorization
APIs, disputes, reporting,
data services.
The APIs are providing
for the real-time data
needs of the customers.
We do have various
channels or integrations
where they can basically
call the APIs which
connect to the gateway.
We have POS devices,
many methods--
tabloids, iPass, whatever the
different payment-accepting
channels, web browser for
e-commerce transactions.
The idea over here is simple.
We have REST APIs exposed
on the gateway, very easy,
covering the industry standard
for transactions, disputes,
reporting, et cetera.
Customers go to it.
Transaction comes
through the gateway.
We mediate the transaction into
the complex internal services
at the gateway, route
the transactions
to the Global Payments
backend processors,
backend processors go
connect to the card brands,
the regular business
response comes back,
and the transaction is either
authorized or declined.
So, the Apigee gateway
basically gives us
a very powerful
abstraction layer
to hide all the
different complexities
we have with our processors.
Those are complex.
These are huge APIs.
Like I said, it mediates
the complexity for us.
Obviously, we have a whole
set of security layer
on top of the gateway.
We leverage a whole bunch
of security policies
for the gateway
or of the gateway.
So, how does this journey begin?
Global Payments did
had API gateways.
We began our journey with
Apigee late December 2017.
A year in it, we purchased the
licenses for US, EU, and AP,
giving us the global
presence of the API gateway
so that we can basically accept
the transactions from all
around the world,
giving us speed
and reliability in a secure
and compliant manner.
55,000 calls in
introduction weekly.
It's growing.
This is-- remember,
we are one year in.
We had the development, QA,
certification, production.
We have a bunch of APIs
already running in production,
and the volume is
growing as we speak.
We had 100% uptime
since we launched.
No downtime.
And again, increasing
adoption across the world,
meaning with this geocapability
or global presence
of the gateway, we now
can accept transactions
from all the corners
of the world.
So, today, the focus would be--
as the focus is on
extension and how we
can accelerate the development.
We at Global Payments do use the
Stackdriver Logging extension.
Why logging?
Why we started with logging?
PCI requirements.
We have to log every
transaction that
is hitting the
gateway, specifically
now as we are launching
transaction APIs, dispute
APIs, all of those, and
moving our internal APIs
on the gateway as well.
Every transaction that hit
the gateway should be logged.
It is in our security
and architecture
practice in Global Payments.
Audit requirements.
We do those from the
fintech industries.
We run through PCI
compliance audit.
We have to show the
evidences of the logs.
How are we collecting the logs?
These logs are then fed
into GCP Stackdriver,
where we have configured
alerting and monitoring
of the logs.
You can navigate to
the issue faster.
All of these logs are
getting fed into Stackdriver
we are alerted.
We are monitoring these logs.
We can navigate through the
logs with different search
parameters in the log
entry and get to this issue
faster in production
environment.
Consistent log-- very important.
I'm going to touch
on that real soon.
Every transaction that
hits the gateway is logged
in a consistent fashion--
who, where, what, why, how.
This is a consistent format
now across every API we have.
Traceability, of course, right?
We have full traceability by
capturing these parameters
of who, where, what, and how.
So, this is how we started with.
We started with logging.
We had to log every transaction
come in the gateway.
So this is how our
Apigee flow looked
without Apigee extensions.
We create the KVMs,
assign the project ID,
log ID, use a variable,
generate the GCP tokens,
use the private key, cache it,
and connect to the GCP project.
Invoke the Stackdriver
service, log it asynchronously
behind the scenes.
And this, if it hits--
there you go.
And this is how it is after
applying the extensions.
Two steps.
You form the log message,
do an Extension Callout
to the Stackdriver
extension that we have
configured via our org admins.
That's it.
Now, the way we use this
extension is this extension
is created in a shared flow and
is implemented at a flow hook
level.
That means that any new proxy
I'm putting on the gateway--
I do not have to worry whether
it is logging or not logging
because, as you know,
if it is in a flow hook,
that is going to be executed.
That's it.
So now any proxy,
whether the developer
remembers to add log, add
extensions, use extensions,
regardless, every transaction
is now getting logged.
This has helped us tremendously
in delivering the proxies
in a right, compliant manner.
I'm logging any proxy
that I put on the gateway.
In fact, a couple of
minutes ago, we just
added one proxy which was
a high term priority for us
in matter of hours.
That's it.
Our proxy is out in
the dev environment.
And very soon, it
will make its way
to the higher environments
of QA, certification, prod,
and so.
So, we do look forward to use
more extensions as now we have
more announcements from Apigee.
DLP is definitely a
cool one, Prithpal.
We definitely want
to look at that.
So we will be using or looking
into using more extensions
at the platform.
Benefits.
So--
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks.
[LAUGHTER]
PRITHPAL BHOGILL: That was
a very powerful use case.
No, let's stay up here.
GOPIKA PATEL: Yeah.
PRITHPAL BHOGILL: So, thanks
for sharing this story, Gopika.
I thought you walked us
through how you're just
very early on in your journey
and are just getting started.
And I'm pretty sure
you guys are going
to hit some very high
volumes very soon.
And we are prepared to
ensure that you folks scale
with your platform
by leveraging Apigee.
And thanks for walking
us through why logging
has become kind of this
new money or currency
that we talk about.
Because from a
compliance perspective,
this becomes super important.
So, I just wanted to
kind of summarize.
We saw a lot of things
happening today.
We spoke about how
do we accelerate
development of these APIs
using cloud services.
We also looked at
some very routine ways
of doing that from the platform,
as we showcased with your--
that comparison was pretty
awesome, by the way, right?
You can still use the platform.
It's completely extensible
to do things like logging
to Stackdriver, as an example.
But then you also
saw extensions were
able to very quickly
compartmentalize them and make
it a one-two show, right?
GOPIKA PATEL: Yep.
PRITHPAL BHOGILL: The
administrators go and configure
it.
And the developers use
policy-based controls.
So we were just
talking about this
when we-- before we came up as
to some of the new extension.
I think the DLP extension,
as you mentioned,
especially the template
support, is becoming very, very
important for customers who are
worried about data security.
And the last piece that you
touched on, I want to re-echo.
Gopika used a term
called "flow hook."
So, one thing which is super
important to understand
is compliance is not an option.
A developer may be
very good at heart
and may remember to do all the
right things such as putting
in all those policies.
But what if they forget?
Ultimately, the
responsibility is
with the program to ensure
that there is compliance.
So flow hook is a mechanism
within the platform where
you can use a
shared flow, the one
that I call from
within my API proxy.
The same shared flow can be
configured at an environment
level so it automatically
applies any policies out there
for all API traffic going
through that environment, which
means from a compliance
perspective you can just
add a shared flow with the
extension for DLP, which
is what we demonstrated.
And you are using Stackdriver
Logging in such a way as well.
And the last thing
to add to that is we
also, with this
announcement, now
provide support for
a post-client flow.
So that means
typically a logging
is a mechanism
which is important,
but you also don't want it to
come in the way of processing
that API call.
So you can now use
the shared flow,
and that policy
more importantly,
in a post-client flow,
which means it can
be done truly asynchronously.
So recapping that, first-class,
extensible, self-service
approach to connect
to cloud services
using these pre-built
extensions very rapidly.
Connect to any service.
We've already built 16 different
extensions that you saw--
12 to different Google
Cloud services, and some
to other providers as well.
And we definitely plan
to continue growing
the catalog of extensions.
The other thing that
we're working on today
is the same framework and the
same development methodology
that we, as the
Apigee team, are using
to build these extensions.
We are planning on
opening up that framework
to our own customers so then
you can take that framework,
build our own extensions,
your own services,
and reuse them within
the enterprise,
just like you can from
the pre-built extensions.
OK.
Awesome.
Thanks, everybody,
for coming on.
GOPIKA PATEL: Thank you, guys.
PRITHPAL BHOGILL: Enjoy
the rest of your day.
[MUSIC PLAYING]